wie läuft es auf dem deutschen
Arbeitsmarkt erfreusting was passiert da
gerade
Frau Baumann sagt wir haben wir haben
keinen Arbeitsmangel wir haben
Arbeitermangel das ist unser Thema
gerade also uns gehen an allen Ecke und
enden die Leute aus ihr Parteikollege
Hubertus Heil der Arbeitsminister war
gerade auf werbetouren Brasilien um was
zu tun Pflegekräfte Fachkräfte
anzuwerben wie funktioniert das wie
läuft das das funktioniert hoffentlich
zunehmend gut weil wir auch das das
fachgerechte Zuwanderungsgesetz mit dem
Fachkräfte Zuwanderungsgesetz die
Einwanderung erleichtern endokratisieren
einfacher machen auch die Anerkennung
ausländischer Berufsabschlüsse und
Berufserfahrungen das ist ja total
kompliziert heutzutage weil man das
deutsche duale berufsausbildungssystem
zum Beispiel sonst nirgends er etabliert
ist das heißt da müssen wir viel viel
besser und einfacher werden auch die
Frage muss denn jemand zum Eintritt in
den deutschen Arbeitsmarkt in jedem
Beruf unbedingt von Anfang an sehr gut
Deutsch sprechen oder wenn es vielleicht
auch in manchen Berufen noch während des
Jobs und während der Integration dann
gelingen vielleicht am Pflegebett ist es
nicht so geschickt da muss man
vielleicht Deutsch sprechen deswegen
werden viele junge Menschen auch
eingeladen hier bei uns in Deutschland
die Ausbildung zu machen währenddessen
Deutsch zu lernen und dann als fertig
ausgebildete deutsch sprechende
Pflegekraft tätig zu werden was auch
hilft gegen den sogenannten brain drain
in dem Fall ist es glaube ich der care
drain oder so was dass wir eben
ausgebildete Pflegekräfte überall
abziehen das sollten wir auch nicht tun
die werden auch woanders gebraucht
funktioniert
das auch bleiben
dann es ist ja so dass gerade im
Pflegebereich jede zehnte Fachkraft in
der Pflege verlässt Deutschland die
wieder Weise sich hier nicht gewährt
schätzt wird und dann eben
Diskriminierung erfährt weil sie mit den
Gehalt logischerweise immer noch nicht
zufrieden ist und ähm
außerhalb Deutschland dürfen
Pflegekräfte
Schwester im Pfleger wesentlich mehr
machen am Patienten als in Deutschland
genau weil wir den eigentlichen Experten
und Expertinnen spricht den
Pflegekräften in Deutschland eben ihre
Expertise absprechen weil wir dieses
System eben haben dass das die
pflegezentralen vorgeben wie viel Zeit
für welche Leistung mit welchem Preis
Schild vollbracht werden darf und weil
wir diesen Pflegekräften eben dadurch
die Expertise absprechen gehen sie
wieder müssen wir nicht erstmal für die
richtigen Bedingungen und für die
richtigen Strukturen gerade in der
Pflege gerade in einer alternden
Gesellschaft sorgen damit die
Pflegekräfte dann zum Beispiel aus
Brasilien auch wirklich bleiben
unbedingt unbedingt wir müssen auch
dafür sorgen dass die Pflegekräfte die
bereits hier sind dass die auch Vollzeit
arbeiten können dass man es aushalten
kann Vollzeit zu arbeiten wir haben ja
eine sehr sehr hohe
Teilzeitquote in Pflegebereich übrigens
auch in vielen anderen Bereichen wo
hauptsächlich Frauen arbeiten es hat ja
was mit familiären Pflichten zu tun die
immer noch die Frauen erledigen und wir
haben natürlich wenn Sie fragen was ist
jetzt auf dem Arbeitsmarkt los während
Corona wahnsinnig viele Frauen in die in
die familiäre kehrarbeit verloren die
haben ihre Arbeitszeit reduziert und da
sind sie auch geblieben bei der
reduzierten Arbeitszeit die kommen nicht
wieder ja da hat ja neulich der IG
metallchef vorgerechnet wenn die 2,5
Millionen Teilzeit arbeiten Mütter nur
eine Stunde mehr arbeiten würden alle
dann haben wir ein Äquivalent von 70.000
neuen Arbeitskräften ja also da ist dann
wäre es schon ziemlicher Mangel behoben
und das ist ja vielleicht auch genau der
perfekte Übergang zu dem Thema wie das
wir reden wollen weil all das trifft
gerade deswegen sagt die voll auf diese
gestresste sich überfordern Gefühle
Gesellschaft trifft also auf einen auf
ein Land davon Arbeitsmarkt in dem
zunehmend das Gefühl entsteht
die Leute wollen möglicherweise gar
nicht mehr so arbeiten dass der Eindruck
der gerade entsteht ist auch eine große
Debatte da draußen gerade die jüngere
Generation hat eine andere Vorstellung
von Arbeit würden sie das so bestätigen
also gibt manche die sagen die sind faul
die wollen einfach nicht mehr die sind
nicht mehr leistungsbereit der der gute
deutsche Fleiß ja das gibt es so nicht
mehr
wie würden sie es bewerten was passiert
da gerade ich glaube genau das ist wir
haben gerade gesagt wir haben heute ein
Arbeitnehmermarkt also das heißt die
Macht liegt heute eigentlich bei den
Arbeitnehmern und da das für ganz viele
Arbeitgeber ist natürlich gerade eine
schwierige Situation weil es total
anders ist weil sich die Arbeitgeber
heute bei den Arbeitnehmern bewerben
müssen weil da gibt's auch ganz viele
verschiedene Zahlen bis 20 30 glaube ich
werden 5 millionenfachkräfte in
Deutschland fehlen wenn wir keine
anderen politischen Maßnahmen einleiten
werden und ich glaube das muss man sich
erstmal klar machen dass das die
Situation ist und das ist irgendwie
ökonomische Grundlage Angebote und
Nachfrage und das erstmal logisch dass
junge Generation aber eigentlich alle
Generation heute andere for vorstellen
können oder viel besser Forderungen
stellen können und wenn man da mal genau
hinguckt weil sie jetzt genau auf diese
Themen direkt die junge Generation ist
faul und nicht mehr diszipliniert nein
nein nein aber das hört man ja immer
wieder
Konflikt würde ich sagen genau
Diskussion und wenn man da aber mal
genau hinguckt also wirklich mal die
Forderung die die junge Generation jetzt
stellt was sind die Bedürfnisse dahinter
weil wir uns das mal genau angucken
Flexibilität werden wir bestimmt auch
mal drauf zu sprechen und vier Tage
Woche ähm was wir darunter so zu mir
eigentlich ist uns allen wichtig dass
wir privat und Beruf vereinbaren können
viele sind einfach nicht gewohnt weil
sie unter anderem umstellen Karriere
gemacht haben dann das Thema Führung
Kultur womit sich jedes Unternehmen
gerade befasst wertschätzende Führung
Führungskräfte die uns nach unseren
Stärken einsetzen und so weiter auch
sinnhafte Tätigkeiten die Jungen der
jungen Generation
vorgeworfen dass sie genau sinnvolle
Tätigkeiten fordert ich glaube es ist
ein großer Gewinn für Unternehmen und
ich glaube uns geht's auch allen so oder
also wollen wir nicht alle sinnvolle
sinnhafte Tätigkeit deswegen glaube ich
so sehr unterscheiden sich die
Generation gar nicht annehmen vielleicht
fühlen uns einmal Simone schmollack an
Kollegin von der Tatsache kennt sie
möglicherweise die sich folgendermaßen
dazu geäußert hat wenn wir mal kurz rein
viele
personalentscheiderinnen und
menschenunternehmen die Leute einstellen
haben mir die willichsten Geschichten
erzählt also da sitzen junge Menschen
vor ihnen die dann eine Vollzeitstelle
achtet von sie gar nicht haben Montag
das gar nicht arbeiten dann komme ich ja
aus dem Wochenende
freitags will ich auch nicht arbeiten da
gehe ich ans Wochenende Dienstag kann
ich mir vorstellen Donnerstag Mittwoch
muss ich aber schon wieder früher gehen
weil ich da Yoga Kurs habe eine
personalentscheiderin die hat sogar
erzählt dass eine junge Frau die wollte
heute entscheiden ob sie morgen
überhaupt arbeiten kommt
so kann man nicht arbeiten also welches
Unternehmen kann so planen
Steffen campeter der
Hauptgeschäftsführer von vom Bund der
Arbeitgeberverbände sagt wir brauchen
endlich wieder mehr Bock auf Arbeit weil
wir haben vergessen oder verlernt das
Geld erwirtschaftet werden muss kommt in
diese Klage und auch dieser das kommt in
das bekannt vor es wird ihm zustimmen
wir brauchen mehr Bock auf Arbeit aber
wir brauchen auch bessere
Voraussetzungen damit wir mehr Bock auf
Arbeit haben
genau so und ich glaube da können wir
ansetzen und wenn wir uns da mal die
Geld ab Studie die wahrscheinlich die
die meisten kennen weil die die jedes
Jahr eigentlich wieder gleich gravieren
schlecht ist die nämlich gesagt dass
rund 85% der Menschen eigentlich nicht
emotional gebunden sind an Ihr
Unternehmen ähm mal das ist ein bisschen
mehr was ein bisschen schlechter aber 90
85 85
genau und wenn man da genau hin guckt
genau was ist was diese 85% die haben
teilweise innerlich gekündigt die sind
nicht mehr wirklich produktiv die sind
nicht wirklich nur die motiviert die ähm
die zeigen wir sind öfter krank die
zeigen öfter auf wenn es fehlen weniger
oft auch wenn es Fehlentwicklung gibt in
Unternehmen und so weiter das ist doch
eine Katastrophe die wir heute doch
haben seit Jahren also müssen wir noch
mal gucken was können wir verändern wenn
man genauer hinguckt gibt es gerade
schon gesagt das Thema Führung und da
kommt auch Geld abzu dass sie sagen wenn
man genau hinguckt ist Führung ist der
Schlüssel für Kultur und das Spiegel mir
auch CEOs und HR verantwortlich immer
wieder
berechne immer wieder dass dass das ein
großes Thema ist Führung und ich mache
den Führungskräften keinen Vorwurf
sondern ich glaube wir müssen in
Deutschland
Führung ist nicht selbstverständlich
nicht jeder kann führen wir müssen
einmal gucken wen wir gerade wirklich
die richtigen Menschen aus die Menschen
führen haben die Interesse an Menschen
und das andere befähigen wir Sie auch
wirklich zu führen und das verändert
sich ja gerade auch noch mal rasant die
Anforderungen
okay prinzipiell alles richtig und ist
sozusagen ein ein wichtiger Aspekt davon
wird trotzdem immer gerne zu diesem
Thema zurück da ist gerade Frau Ebeling
also auch ihre Migration die Generation
Z so ein bisschen in den Fokus geraten
als sozusagen die die dünnhäutigen die
keinen Bock auf Arbeit Thomas der mir
sehr hat sich dieser Tage dazu geäußert
und sagte die Anspruchshaltung vieler in
dieser Generation geht mir gegen den
Strich und sagte dann insgesamt sind wir
nicht fleißig genug wir haben die
höchste Zahl ist interessant von
Erwerbstätigen aber gleichzeitig wird
das Arbeitsvolumen immer geringer weil
immer weniger in Vollzeit arbeiten mit
anderen Worten das was sie auch neulich
in die Diskussion geworfen haben vier
Tage Woche
warum ist das so es ist sozusagen dieser
dieser ja dieser berühmte deutsche Fleiß
ist das etwas was sie als Generation
eher ablehnen was ihn verdächtig ist wo
sie sagen ne komm wir legen Wert auf
andere Dinge das brauchen wir nicht mehr
naja erstmal und die Diskussion
vielleicht ein bisschen zu entschärfen
die Dinge die gerade die Kollegen von
der Tat in der Mats aufgezeigt hat gibt
es natürlich in der Tat gibt es aber
auch in jeder anderen Generation also es
gibt auch faule Menschen in der
Babyboomer Generation und in allen
Generationen dazwischen und es gibt eben
andere Menschen die ein bisschen mehr
Drive haben und die sich auch eben
stärker mit den Job identifizieren mir
ist es wichtig also Frau Bornheim hat
das ja eben gerade schon gesagt dass A
alle Generationen auf den von den
Veränderungen auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
profitieren und dass die Forderung der
jungen Generation häufig ja auch
eigentlich ein Resultat ist die sie bei
den bei der älteren Generation
beobachtet haben spricht die Learnings
der älteren Generation die Punkte unter
den sie gelitten haben also besonders
unter Stress gelitten haben im Job dass
sie das Väter zum Teil wegen der klaren
Rollen oder veralteten Rollenverteilung
ihre Kinder nicht gesehen haben dass
Frauen nach Hause abgedriftet sind bzw
mehr für die kehrarbeit bis heute
verantwortlich sind und dadurch ihm
häufig auch von Altersarmut fahren
betroffen sind und von Männern eben auch
finanziellen Partnerschaften abhängig
sind das sind ja alles Links die wir bei
den unseren elterngenerationen bei den
älteren Generationen beobachtet haben
und daraus resultieren er jetzt
eigentlich unsere Forderung und
natürlich kann man das jetzt irgendwie
plakativ formulieren und die Yogamatte
ins Spiel bringen und so weiter es ist
alles immer zugespitzt genau zum Teil
sehr originell und zum Teil auch nicht
aber trotzdem mal der Idee nachspüren
sozusagen ob sich da die Sicht auf
Arbeit verändert hat das ist ja
interessante Punkt ich glaube Arbeit ist
heute nicht mehr der Lebensinhalt von
vielen jungen Menschen also klar wir
müssen auch unsere Miete bezahlen das
ist eine ganz relevanter Fakt ich meine
jeder dritte Studierende lebt laut dem
paritätischen wohlstandsverband den
Armut laut demnach sind sogar 80% der
alleinlebenden Studierenden aufgrund der
hohen Mietkosten von Armut betroffen wir
müssen natürlich irgendwie wohnen und
und unser Leben finanzieren gleichwohl
bedeutet arbeitet eben nicht mehr unser
komplettes Inhalt also die
Identifikation ist nicht mehr so stark
und das spiegelt ja eben auch die
galux-studie die Frau Bornheim eben
erwähnt hat eben auch wieder und wir
müssen sie ist das so schlecht weil
gerade ein bisschen
die Situation die wir gerade beschrieben
haben wieder Arbeitsmarkt ist und ist
auch das Thema wir sind wir haben ein
ganz anderes Wohlstandsniveau also die
junge Generation das sage ich immer sie
finden ein schönes Bild ist ganz oben
auf der Bedürfnispyramide angekommen und
da steht schon wirklich irgendwo
Selbstverwirklichung steht ein Thema
also dass wir das ist ja auch eine
privilegierte Situation
sagen können dass wir heute sagen können
uns ist es wichtig dass der Job nicht
mehr nur dafür da ist dass wir unser
Lebensunterhalt finanzieren können
sondern dass wir auch eine sinnhafte
Tätigkeit haben aber sinnhafte Tätigkeit
muss man sich also die Sinnfrage muss
man sich ja erstmal leisten können zu
stellen und ich glaube gerade in diesen
multiplen Krisenzeiten ist es gar nicht
so verkehrt gerade wenn wir uns an
unsere mentale Gesundheit denken uns
eben nicht so stark mit dem Job zu
identifizieren denn der kann im Zweifel
auch mal wegfallen auch wenn hier gerade
ein relativ stabiles Arbeitslosen Niveau
haben in Deutschland aber wir kennen das
ja oder haben es in der Finanzkrise
2007/2008 gesehen dass die psychischen
Erkrankungen die aufgrund von
Jobverlusten in dieser Krise entstanden
sind auch noch Jahre später obwohl dann
wo wir schon wieder eine stabile
wirtschaftliche und finanzielle
Situation hatten eben auch noch Jahre
später angehalten haben aber was hat was
hat das für Auswirkungen dann auf ihre
Generation das bedeutet eben dass wir
auch da wieder ein Learning bei unseren
bei unserer Eltern gerne haben diesen
Job Verluste erlebt haben genau unter
anderem also ich meine ich bin jetzt 26
in mein Vater hat damals seinen Job
verloren und war in dieser Zeit
arbeitssuchend das heißt ich zum
Beispiel habe das sehr radikal miterlebt
sie dürfen sofort von Borowski ist dann
die Konsequenz daraus nicht dass man
sagt damit mir das nicht passiert lege
ich lieber noch mal eine Schippe drauf
das war immer unsere Reflex zu sagen
okay dann lass uns anstrengen damit uns
das nicht wieder fährt unsere Eltern
haben ja solche Dinge auch erlebt ne ich
mache uns jetzt einfach mal so ungefähr
Leistungsversprechen was wir meine
Generation in diesem Sinne aber nicht
mehr Geld das heißt auch wenn nicht mehr
Leiste bedeutet das ja nicht dass ich
unbedingt unterm Strich wirklich mehr
rausbekommen also wenn wir uns zum
Beispiel die OECD Studie angucken das
sehen wir das immer weniger junge
Menschen das medialen Einkommen in
Deutschland erreichen das heißt unsere
Mittelschicht bröckelt quasi was die
jungen Menschen angeht nach unten hinweg
wir können wir haben vorhin über
Eigenheim und über Wärmepumpen und so
weiter gesprochen das ist für junge
Menschen natürlich auch in dem Sinn ein
Thema weil das sich im Zweifel auch in
den Mieten widerspiegelt aber die
wenigsten jungen Menschen haben eben
Eigenheimen z.B wir können Sie
das was da durchkommt ist ja eigentlich
was anderes dass das interessante also
niemand hat mit Mitte 20 oder mit Anfang
20 Eigenheim ist eine NS Erbe was geht
um die Frage ist das erstrebenswert und
das würde ich gerne mal verstehen also
sie wollen das gar nicht sie streben das
gar nicht an das ist nicht der Traum im
reinen Endhaus mit der schönen neuen
Wärmepumpe zu sitzen und und alles läuft
und und die Rente ist auch sicher und
das Leben wird immer besser und im
Zweifel die Mallorca Flüge immer
häufiger so wie es ja viele aus meiner
Generation als sozialen Aufstieg ja
erlebt haben das waren jetzt sehr viele
Punkte also den Mallorca Flug lasse ich
jetzt mal außen vor was das Thema Rente
betrifft 70 % der jungen Menschen haben
laut damit Haare Renten studiert Angst
vor Altersarmut das heißt das ist
durchaus ein Thema sie sehen und sich
dadurch aus nach Sicherheit und ähm aber
und auch nach einem Eigenheim
beziehungsweise einem Ort wo Sie zum
Beispiel eine Familie gründen könnte
und das ist eben auch ein ganz
interessanter Aspekt der auch stark mit
dem Arbeitsmarkt in Verbindung steht
dass ich gerade junge Frauen junge
Menschen insgesamt aber gerade junge
Frauen aus diesen Gründen immer häufiger
bewusst gegen eine Familie entscheiden
das ist eine Entwicklung die wir schon
seit Jahren beobachten können indem eben
auch das Alter in dem Frauen ihr erstes
Kind bekommen eben seit Jahren weiter
anstieg und mittlerweile entscheiden
sich eben auch besonders häufig Frauen
mit akademischen Hintergrund bewusst
gegen Kindern
ein anderes Thema ich wirklich trotzdem
nochmal der Frage nachspielen das führt
dann dazu dass man eher weniger arbeiten
möchte als dass man mehr arbeiten möchte
das will ich gerade verstehen also wenn
man Angst hat vor Altersarmut wenn man
sagt wir können uns das Eigenheim nicht
leisten warum führt das dann dazu zu
sagen aber trotzdem bitte vier Tage
Woche reicht wir wollen uns nicht kaputt
machen und aufreiben das will ich mal
Korrelation Korrelation und Kausalität
und es muss ja nicht zusammenhängen das
ist eben gleichzeitig da einerseits
dieses
[Musik]
einer hat die kleine Kinder und sagte er
nachmittags um 4 Uhr ich müsste jetzt
mal nach Hause meine Kinder abholen es
fanden wir zum Kopfschütteln ja wir
haben 70 Stunden gearbeitet das ist aber
sie haben unsere Kinder
unsere Kinder gucken sich das an und
sagen nee das will ich echt nicht ja
am Ende die die Väter in Rente gehen mit
mit 65 66 67 und fallen in ein tiefes
Loch weil plötzliches Leben weg ist
so sehr lebensinformation genau
sehr sehr viele Männer die jetzt gerade
in Rente gehen wieder spiegeln das ist
tatsächlich bereuen so wenig Zeit mit
ihren Kindern verbracht zu haben
ist es schon irgendwie interessant weil
die die Arbeitsmarktsituation ist ja für
Arbeitnehmer so gut
so dass dann diese Sorgen ich glaube die
kommen eher woanders her weil und auch
Gehälter sind extrem hoch also die ich
habe viel damit Arbeitgebern zu tun die
beschweren sich eigentlich dass wir so
viele Gehälter sein lassen und weil
einfach die Forderung so hoch sind und
das ist schon interessant dass das so so
unterschiedlich ist
eine Generationen weiter ist genau
zwischen zwischen uns allen
dieses dass man nicht mehr auf einer
Party selbstverständlich fragt was man
was man arbeitet oder so das ist schon
da verändert sich was und da das sind
dann so Momente wo ich mich alt fühle
weil tatsächlich ich ähm mich sehr stark
immer mit meiner Arbeit mit meiner
Ausbildung mit allem identifiziert habe
und immer Vollzeit gearbeitet habe
obwohl ich Kinder habe und das auch und
übrigens also mit diesem was man bereut
ne es gibt natürlich auch viele
ältere Frauen die ich kenne die sagen
hätte ich mal vielleicht mehr gearbeitet
ne also ich vielleicht interessanteren
Job gehabt also wie man am Ende
zurückblickt auf sein Leben dann gibt's
immer diesen Satz Leute sagen am
Sterbebett niemand sagt ich hätte gerne
mehr gearbeitet ja aber sozusagen das
ist ich würde auch sowas vielleicht
immer nicht überbewerten mein Gefühl ist
wenn ich so darauf Schau
ist schon dass diese Frage
diese Lifestyle Frage schon auch eine
ist die unter privilegierten Akademikern
geführt wird ja und dass man deswegen
finde ich auch diese Vermischung aus
Verunsicherung von Menschen die
irgendwie sich nicht das Leben nicht
mehr leisten können dass die dann
weniger arbeiten wollen ist auch mir
nicht plausibel und das deckt sich
übrigens auch nicht mit der empirischen
Erfahrung die man auch machen kann
übrigens auch in Amerika wo wo und auch
in Deutschland ist das so wenn man
Universitätsprofessoren fragt wer sind
eigentlich eure besten Studenten ja dann
sind das häufig nicht die privilegierten
Akademiker Kinder die sowieso schon
nicht nur Erben sondern sowieso schon
wissen dass sie ausgesorgt haben sondern
das sind häufig Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund soziale Aufsteiger
die wissen sie müssen richtig haben
asiatische
hart arbeiten und die dann auch so mit
so ein bisschen ja so herabschauen auf
sozusagen diese in Amerika häufig dann
unambitionierten so die die sich dann
irgendwie mit sich selber beschäftigen
und da gibt es schon so eine Art GAP und
das ist ja auch in Deutschland so und
deswegen ich höre auch von Anwälten aus
Großkanzleien dann so die Klage die dann
sagen ja wir jedes Jahr liegen wir
10.000 Euro Einstiegsgehalt drauf und
jetzt ist schon teilweise 140.000 Euro
oder sogar mehr Einstiegsgehalt und die
Leute sagen sind
mittlerweile in Deutschland für für und
trotzdem sagen die Leute ja weiß ich
nicht muss ich überlegen und ich möchte
aber gerne folgende Sonderkonditionen
das dann auch diese Partner aus den
Kanzleien sagen was wollt ihr denn
eigentlich noch ja also wir wirklich
12 Euro die Stunde erhöht haben nicht
auf 82 also ich verstehe viel weniger
verdient haben die halt nicht verstehen
dass es nicht nur ums Gehalt geht und
trotzdem sind durch solche Diskussionen
wirklich sozusagen ein ein einer Ebene
von von total privilegierten das dass
diejenigen die dann irgendwie sagen ich
möchte aber irgendwie das Geld ist mir
nicht so wichtig und so das muss man
leisten können
auch wenn ich das so sagen darf ein Teil
dieser Debatte von von irgendwie nein
natürlich ist work-life balance total
wichtig natürlich ist das alles absolut
berechtigte Frage ich glaube auch dass
man wenn man in die 60er Jahre schaut ja
Wirtschaftswunder regelmäßig sind Männer
am Herzinfarkt gestorben natürlich
wollen wir das nicht ja natürlich kann
man auch manche Dinge mit ein bisschen
mehr Distanz sehen aber
dass das Arbeit irgendwo etwas ist nicht
nur was dieses Land irgendwie
voranbringen sondern auch etwas erfüllen
das sein kann
nur weil Arbeit nicht mehr das Zentrum
unseres Lebens ausmacht bedeutet das ja
nicht dass uns Arbeit keine Spaß mehr
macht und dass wir nicht auch Freude
daran haben Leistung zu erbringen aber
deswegen sage ich ehrlich gesagt viele
Arbeiten machen halt keinen Spaß und
irgendjemand muss sie trotzdem machen
also sozusagen
obwohl es diese sehr privilegierten
Menschen eben auch gibt das ist Fakt
aber deswegen habe ich auch ganz zu
Anfang eben die Pflegebranche
angesprochen weil wir eben auch über
diese Branchen sprechen müssen weil wir
die strukturell auch erstmal attraktiver
machen müssen um die Menschen da
aufzufangen und eben dafür zu sorgen
dass wir nicht von einer ja sehr
privilegierten Bubble sprechen die
einfach immer mehr mehr fordert und eben
einer Bubble die auch gerne mehr fordern
möchte auch eben um Ihre mentale
Gesundheit zu schützen weil sie sowieso
schon ich meine wir wissen ja wenn man
den armuts schon aufgewachsen ist dann
ist man noch eher davon betroffen eben
im Laufe der Berufsjahre zu Erkrankung
das heißt sie haben auch die Tendenz
sich eigentlich schützen zu wollen weil
sie natürlich jeden Tag merken okay ich
kratze hier gerade an meiner Grenze aber
sie haben eben häufig nicht hinbekommen
aufwachsen die sagen ich möchte aber
hier wie die Kollegin von der Tatze
geschrieben hat ich möchte aber Montag
und Freitag nicht arbeiten und da habe
ich meine junge Arbeit und da ich glaube
nicht dass die Menschen arbeiten
womöglich schnell in die Situation dass
sie nicht anders arbeiten können ja also
dass sie weniger arbeiten müssen als
Vollzeit weil sie eben zum Beispiel
Kinder haben weil die Kita nicht mehr
den ganzen Tag
Betreuungszeiten anbieten kann weil das
Personal fehlt weil die Schule nur
halbtags offen hat in Deutschland in
Frankreich vier Tage die Woche Ganztag
das ist dort völlig normal Standard bei
uns die Ausnahme die Nische Tagespflege
die Nische ja also man kommt einfach in
Situationen wo man nicht Vollzeit
arbeiten kann einfach unser arbeitszeug
muss sich darauf einrichten mehr
Flexibilität anzubieten und mehr auf die
Bedürfnisse von Beschäftigten einzugehen
in dem Zusammenhang bin ich auf diese
Diskussion ja auch ein Stück weit
gekommen ich habe einen eine Rehaklinik
bei mir zu Hause im Wahlkreis die machen
seit Jahren schon vier Tage Woche 36
Stunden also 9 Stunden Schichten 36
Stunden sind bei den Vollzeit bei
Lohnausgleich haben die gemacht die
haben viel mehr Bewerbungen höre aber
beschäftigungsanteile weniger Gesundheit
weniger Fluktuationen die Leute sind
super zufrieden weil sie den einen Tag
mehr Flexibilität
macht ist die Kompensation sozusagen
weniger arbeiten damit man leben würde
aber im Moment widersprechen viele
Pflegekräfte machen ihren Job richtig
gern und finden ihn erfüllend aber super
stressig und super belastend auch
deshalb weil immer Überstunden gemacht
werden müssen weil sie wenig Personal da
ist weil eben die Belastung natürlich
ist die minutenpflege auch noch mal ein
Thema ganz klar ja aber die machen ihren
Job gern also ich war auch wirklich sehr
gerne und fand es erfüllen Paketboten zu
sein zum Beispiel
Spaß machen oder das ist normal
sprechen
keinen Spaß gemacht haben
mein erster Job war einigungskraft in
der Fleischerei für 5 € die Stunde
hat mir wirklich viel Spaß gemacht weil
die Leute da toll waren weil ich weil
wir gute Strukturen im Team hatten das
war mein erster Job der mich geprägt hat
danach habe ich in einem Hotel kellnert
und die Zimmer sauber gemacht das damit
bin ich also damals in den Augen meiner
mitschüler:innen eigentlich
gesellschaftlich aufgestiegen bei
Kellnern ist ja eigentlich cooler als in
einer Fleischerei zu putzen dieser Job
hat mir überhaupt keinen Spaß gemacht
weil die Strukturen falsch waren das
heißt ich glaube darin liegt wirklich
ein Schlüssel und sie haben ihm gesagt
wir brauchen aus Jobs wir brauchen auch
Leute die die Jobs machen die keiner
machen will
wir waren eben beim Stichwort pflege ich
glaube viele Leute wollten pflegen und
viele Leute sie haben es eben gesagt
empfinden den Pflege als sinnstiftend
nur was wir gerade eben haben die
Strukturen sind falsch deswegen werden
wir meiner Meinung nach ihm später auch
das Problem haben dass viele
Pflegekräfte aus z.B Brasilien früher
oder später wieder abwandern werden weil
die Strukturen nicht stimmt ich glaube
das ist ein entscheidender Schlüssel